[Music]
welcome back as tensions rise between
the united states and russia over
ukraine vladimir putin is laying the
blame on the west claiming he fears nato
expansion into the region
he also is claiming he is not looking
for a fight saying this week quote armed
conflicts and bloodshed are absolutely
not something we would choose here with
reaction is fox news contributor and
former secretary of state mike pompeo mr
pompeo good morning to you and uh happy
christmas eve
thank you happy christmas eve to you
steve it's great to be with you this
morning
what do you make of mr putin saying yeah
don't blame us blame the west uh he was
also asked uh will you guarantee you
won't invade ukraine and he goes
no
well vladimir putin's been on the stage
for an awfully long time he knows full
well that latvia estonia
they're not going to invade russia he
knows this it's kind of it's a it's a
fake victimization to assert somehow
that he feels threatened from those
countries for an invasion he's the one
that's raised the tension that fault
lies with him but there's fault in the
biden administration too when uh when he
when putin saw what happened in
afghanistan
the terrible tragedy of 13 americans
being killed and real weakness being
shown when we gave him the opportunity
to finish his pipeline to have energy
control over germany he saw american
weakness and so i think what you've seen
over these past days and weeks is him
building up putting pressure on the
americans looking for concessions trying
to achieve something through
threats and coercion that he he doesn't
want to do militarily but he's perfectly
prepared to push the bite administration
to the edge to see if he can't get what
he'd really like
and you know mr secretary when the
president of the united states uh had a
virtual summit with mr putin a couple of
weeks ago he said joe biden said if you
invade
uh you know they're going to be heavy
economic sanctions is that big enough
you know and he said
for the most part military hardware off
the table is that enough of a big stick
you know against the backdrops dude we
forget in just this year it's been it's
been a long year uh the first uh 11
months now the administration we forget
uh the fro was russia they shut down a
pipeline inside the united states
closing off gasoline to the united
states for days
and
president biden said don't do that again
i made what turned out to be a pretty
idle threat there were no real costs
imposed that we're aware of so i suspect
putin takes those threats with a grain
of salt it's going to take firm resolve
demonstrated resolve not just words but
deeds and a preparedness and a
demonstration of preparedness from the
by administration to stop putin from
acting in this coercive way
sure
um
i you know i remember you from when you
were our kansas congressman
what sort of traditions family cans and
traditions did you have at christmas
time mr secretary
you know we had a couple one of my
favorites was that every year our family
would gather together we would make the
secret pompeo
mercer fudge recipe it came from my
mom's side of the family was her mother
grace mercer's recipe
i released it when i was ca director we
thought it'd be fun to take a secret
recipe and release it when you were the
ci director
and we make it every year
my mom was mom was clearly in charge dad
and i and my brother and sister were the
labor but it was always joyous we would
make fudge we'd distribute it to people
in the neighborhood and teachers and the
like steve you know the kinds of things
families do together now my family my
wife susan my son nick and his fiancee
rachel will repeat that
now this year and it's a lot of fun just
to gather around in the kitchen to talk
and to to work a little bit and to do a
good turn for friends and people we love
well that's great obviously the fudge
recipe has been declassified because we
just put it on tv you know one of the
ducey family traditions i would always
take tape the children running down the
stairs and i showed that a couple of
days ago the other thing we do every
christmas eve and we'll do it tonight
our town has a sing-along where
everybody gathers and we sing actual
christmas carols and i think we've got
some pictures of it where the kids do
the singing they hand out the sheet
music
and uh there you can see right there
it's dark uh peter ducey has got the
flashlight he is also the town's uh
deepest voice he's got the uh the best
baritone
as they recreate 12 days of christmas
the duceys were
two turtle doves very nice anyway and
there we are we're seeing lots of them
mike's thank you very much for watching
oh
it's christmas
anything goes uh mr pompeo thank you
very much for joining us and uh merry
christmas to you bless you merry merry
christmas to you all as well
i tell you what mr pompeo uh could we
put that recipe on fox and friends so we
could share it with everybody
yeah that'd be awesome steve i would
love that susan and my and my my mother
who's passed away now would love that as
well
okay so folks uh give us a half an hour
and we will get a link to uh the family
secret fudge recipe all right mike thank
you very much merry christmas
thanks steve so long sir